[Music]
the emotional affair as opposed to the
physical affair is really just what it
sounds like which is being emotionally
invested in someone other than your main
partner where you are confiding in them
usually intimate details that normally
would be reserved for your partner and
starting to invest in them that could be
through say a flirtation that gives you
a feeling of gratification that normally
would come from your partner the
emotional energy that it takes to keep a
stable long-term relationship going
that becomes invested in somebody else
is essentially being siphoned off from
your main partner they often do turn
into a physical affair
they're often just sort of the gateway
on the way there you're not telling your
partner what you're telling this other
person you're not telling your partner
what you feel about this other person so
it is it is a secret
it is a betrayal because you know that
if your partner could see what you are
doing with this other person they would
be hurt they would take it as a betrayal
and it's healthy to at times have a
thought about someone else but this now
becomes not just about thoughts this
becomes about actions sure letsa yeah
let's have a drink after work or you're
touching their arm or you're thinking
I'm going to wear this sexy outfit to
work today because I'm going to see so
and so I'm really hoping that they're
going to notice and then you know we're
going to have a little flirtation I'm
going to get some of that great feeling
that I get when they have a response to
me one of the more common stories for
couples come in to see me wear something
like this has gone on is it started with
I contacted or was contacted by an old
boyfriend or girlfriend on Facebook
super common seems like it should be
innocent and but it's kind of cool and
then you get that little ooh that fells
nice and you start interacting with them
and because it's by computer you feel
like it's safe right I'm not so
in them I'm not physically with them but
you're tossing a little something out
they're tossing a little something out
and it becomes this slippery slope not
that you can never talk to somebody who
was ever in your past before but if
you're going to no flirting no seduction
no complaining about your current
relationship that is hugely important
stay away from alcohol with people that
something might be a little bit starting
with because when inhibitions come down
that's when problems get started think
about what you would be hurt by if your
spouse were doing the same thing with
somebody else and then also think about
is there something you're looking for
that is drawing you to this that's not
happening in your current relationship
and focus your energies on how you can
deal with that so maybe there is
something happening in the bedroom that
is not great or it's not happening at
all that is is making you feel like well
I need I need to feel good about myself
somehow it's not a dalliance that has no
repercussion it often is the the end of
a relationship if one person or the
other goes down
[Music]